[Musique]
l'ex entraîneur de Versailles a été
condamné aujourd'hui à huit mois de
prison assorti d'un sursis probatoire
pendant 24 mois avec obligation de soins
pour rappel en novembre dernier il avait
été mise à pied par le club de football
il était soupçonné d'avoir filmé des
femmes à leur insu 13 % des stations
services sont à court de carburant en
France et dans le département des
Yvelines on compte moins de 1% des
stations services en rupture totale et
7% en rupture partielle des rencontres
entre professionnels d'entreprises et
élèves de 3e et 4e seront organisés ce
jeudi 23 mars à La Verrière l'événement
est organisé par la Fondation faciles
qui agit contre l'exclusion et ce jeudi
une vingtaine de professionnels et 150
jeunes participeront à ces échanges le
but est de leur permettre de découvrir
des métiers et de les accompagner dans
leur choix d'orientation scolaire et
professionnelle la Course du Coeur vouée
à sensibiliser aux dons d'organes à
démarrer
[Musique]